hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter 6 of his work language truth
and logic a jair is going to assert that
moral disagreement in the sense that we
typically think about it which includes
attempts to convince other people that
our position is right on moral issues or
ethical issues and that their position
is wrong is actually impossible that it
can't work the way that we think that it
does now his basis for saying this is in
fact the emotivist theory of ethics
which he articulates throughout that
chapter and which is perfectly you know
consistent and compatible with the
logical positivist project that he's got
going in the work so we should think
about what what does the emotivist
theory or perspective on ethics say it
says that that when we're using ethical
terms and and asserting what we take to
be ethical or moral propositions we're
not actually making assertions in the
way that we would about tangible you
know physical objects that we can easily
agree upon or just
hurry up hon there's issues of value
involved and and the value part isn't
really a matter of fact at all it's not
something that we can come to some sort
of reasoned agreement about because all
we're really doing is expressing what he
calls at one point moral sentiment a
little bit later he will talk about
expressing emotions and those emotions
are things like saying stealing is wrong
amounting basically to staying stealing
oh don't like it that you know and and
it doesn't have to be even assertions
that one has emotions it's just
expressing emotions so what this means
is that in what we take to be moral
disagreements like you shouldn't steal
from your employer even if your employer
is being mean to you right there's a
nice ethical proposition neither side is
really asserting any genuine proposition
and we have to be careful because he
does say there may be some things that
are genuine propositions you could say
your employer is in fact treating you
badly it's possible for you to take
money out of the till or you know
transfer accounts or things like those
are genuine propositions because those
are empirical although treating you
badly now that we think about it
analyzing that that's a moral
proposition as well but on a surface it
looks as if it's a factual proposition
right we could define treating badly in
terms of some sociological or
psychological facts though so neither
side is actually asserting genuine
propositions instead the ethical terms
in the arguments or positions are in
fact expressing our feelings positive or
negative or are they're doing one other
thing they're trying to get others to
feel the same sort of thing so that's
the the theory that he's working with
what is the upshot well then it becomes
impossible
to dispute as he says about questions of
value like is it okay to repay evil with
evil right the more genuine more general
rather idea behind the well my employer
is treating me badly so I should steal a
little bit on the side too you know
remedy it in some way those would not be
things you can actually dispute about
why well as heir says disputes are going
to be about matters of fact things that
we can agree upon now these these could
be matters of fact in the sense of you
know the truck is is white or I have one
piece of chalk in my hand things that we
can verify with our senses they might
also be what we could call psychological
or sociological facts where we say well
in this society what is considered fair
play or a justice is this right now
that's not saying that that justice
really is that it's just saying these
people think of things in this way so
disputes are always about those sorts of
matters and we can dispute about them
back and forth and back and forth what
we try to do is get the other person he
says to agree about empirical facts and
he's got some nice examples in here he
says that for example if we say that you
know thrift is a virtue and somebody
else says thrift is a vice what are what
are we going to do well we'll talk about
the nature of what we mean by thrift and
what a virtue would be and why it would
be you know considered to be a good
thing overall to be thrifty and we could
go on and on but it's always going to be
factual stuff with the value stuff sort
of being presupposed or driving the
inquiry he you know he's got a nice
example here says when someone disagrees
with us about the moral value of a
certain act
type of action we do admittedly resort
to argument and try to win them over to
our way of thinking but we do not
attempt to show by our arguments he has
the wrong ethical feeling that would be
the value part towards a situation whose
nature he is correctly apprehended what
we attempt to show is he's mistaken
about the facts of the case so here's
the examples we argue he has
misconceived the agents motive or that
he's misjudged the effects of the action
or it's probable effects in view of the
agent's knowledge or he's failed to take
into account the special circumstances
in which the agent was placed or we
employ more general arguments about the
effects which actions of a certain type
tend to produce or the qualities which
are usually manifested in their
performance why do we do this why do we
go through all this this back-and-forth
about that he says our hope is that we
have only to get our opponent to agree
with us about the nature of the
empirical facts for him to adopt the
same moral attitude towards them as we
do so if we see somebody behaving in a
way that we think is bad and somebody
else thinks it's good we try to explain
to them why you know where the badness
lies right well it's in their motive
they have this particular motive let's
take a great example somebody gives a
lot of money to charity but we know that
they're doing it for nefarious purposes
to try to gather you know prestige to
themselves so that they can thereby gain
a foothold in the political
establishment and eventually produce
tyranny which we think is a bad thing
right we assume that the other person
thinks Tierney's a bad thing and we say
to them can't you see what this person
is actually doing you know and we get
all worked up about it usually because
our our emotions are getting involved
and they say I see what they're doing
but I don't see it the same way that you
do I don't see this as like this
slippery slope down to tyranny the way
that that you assume it is I mean think
about all the major controversial
hot-button issues that we have going on
in our society that people get very
worked up about and you might you know
think that there's something to what air
talking about so the hope is that the
other person if they can just get the
fats right will actually share our moral
attitudes what often is the case we
actually get agreement about many of the
facts of the case and it turns out that
we don't actually agree we still hold
opposite positions and in that case what
Ayer says is going on is that we have
differences in what we what he calls
moral education or and he puts it in
quotes conditioning that is people have
been raised in different ways with
different sets of values and so for
example some people think it's very
important to you know work all the time
and make as much of yourself as you can
and not let any time go to waste so that
you can be productive and other people
have the attitude that well that makes
you a stupid sucker you know you should
actually take it easy as much as you can
and skim as much as possible out of the
system and air would say well you know
different people grew up in different
households and different societies and
thereby they have these different
attitudes and there's really nothing you
can do to convince a person that the
basic moral attitudes or presupposed
values that they have are the wrong ones
because they're not the wrong ones there
aren't any right or wrong when it comes
to values they simply are the what we
have now of course what do we do he says
so we typically will say that the other
person has distorted or underdeveloped
moral sense or sensibilities or values
either one of those people over there
who lack values we often say when we say
somebody lacks values they don't
actually lack values they lack the
values that we would like them to have
according to err all right so that's as
far as we can really get is the bedrock
of values an heir goes on to say listen
without agreement on these basic moral
values you really can't have argument
that both sides are going to understand
and agree with in or
to resolve moral disagreements he says
we find argument as possible on moral
questions only if some system of values
is presupposed if our opponent concurs
with us and expressing moral disapproval
of all actions of a given type T then we
can get him to condemn a particular
action a by bringing forward arguments
to show that a is tight is of type T for
the question of whether a does or does
not belong to that type that's a plain
question of fact he says but you know
given that a man has certain moral
principles we argue that he must in
order to be consistent react morally to
certain things in a certain way what we
do not and cannot argue about is the
validity of these moral principles we
merely praise or condemn them in the
light of our own feelings so he says if
you doubt this try to construct an
imaginary argument on a question of
value that does not reduce itself to an
argument of a question of logic or an
empirical matter of fact and you won't
be able to come up with a single example
now what he means is one that's that's
actually resolvable it turns out that
there's all sorts of disagreements that
we have that if air is right we cannot
resolve we cannot deal with other than
in an emotivist way by expressing our
own feelings and trying through that
expression to convince the other person
that they ought to feel the same way as
we do and if they feel the same way then
they'll accept our thinking on it
otherwise we can present our thinking
and they can even accept our thinking
and say we're still wrong and they
disagree so according to err the process
of dealing with moral disagreements is
only partly rational the side of it
that's actually rational is the
marshaling of facts and evidence for our
side but driving the entire process is
this entire realm of presupposed values
what he calls systems of values that
we've arrived at in non rational
ways
you